third row on the fourth four seat in
Steve Paul in tunas ESPN Brazil even
though you lost it seemed like in that
fourth quarter
you guys were flying around diving on
loose balls and just playing really
really hard considering all the
adversity you guys are going through
here in the playoffs how proud are you
of your guys tonight oh very proud they
played really really hard and gave it
everything they had and just ran into a
better team tonight Toronto played an
excellent game made big shots every time
they needed to we never could get over
the hump every time we've fought back
and kind of got it to six seven or eight
whatever it was they made big shots so
they outplayed us they deserved it and
but I'm very proud of our effort and now
we've just got to bounce back and
hopefully get back here in here Friday
night hopefully get get a little
healthier and get some guys back but
we'll see we'll see how that goes but
main thing is just got to play better
tonight one of the best you've ever seen
Steph was incredible the stuff he does
is he does things that honestly I don't
think anybody has ever done before the
way he plays the game the way he shoots
it and the combination of his ball
handling and and shooting skills
it's incredible to watch he was amazing
second row and you're right coach Krista
Creek USA today you obviously want to
err on the side of caution when it comes
to injuries but was there any of the
mentality of lose the battle win the war
as it relates to sitting clay tonight
well the whole point was to not risk a
bigger injury that would keep him out of
the rest of the series so that was the
decision we made and
I feel very comfortable with it I never
would have forgiven myself if if I
played him tonight and and he had gotten
hurt so you live with the decision you
make a wise decision the wisest one you
can and you live with it and you move
forward so the good thing is clay has
done well the last two days now he's got
another couple of days to heal hopefully
he'll be out there fry him Tim over here
beep Tim Cal Comedy athletic the
decision enclave did it really come down
to last minute or had it basically been
made maybe even an hour or so or maybe
even earlier not to play them that's you
know internal business Jared on the
right side coach Jared Greenberg MBA TV
based on how many guys you do have out
whether it be in the game tonight or as
you start to look forward to Friday were
you at all concerned about minutes and
usage of Steph and DeMarcus and some of
those guys yeah you know it's one of the
reasons we you know didn't have Andre on
the floor at the end of the game you
know for those last five minutes he was
up over 30 minutes and you know this is
the only these are the only two games in
the series where there's just one day
off so we tried to watch Shaun
Livingston minutes and and you know
DeMarcus had had something going on late
in the game he left the bench to get
checked out and so you know we the guys
we pushed were dream on and stuff but
they're you know they're in the primes
of their lives so they're capable of
handling them yeah I think he's fine and
I think he they just he he went to the
locker room with about maybe three four
minutes left just to get checked out I
think he's fine coach Richt it'll 95
seven the game in sports by a lion when
you were trying to think of where you're
gonna get these points tonight without
Katie and without clay if you had known
that stuff was gonna go for 47 and dream
on for 17 17 did you think maybe that
would be enough
I just knew we were gonna score 109
points cuz that's all we're gonna do the
rest of this series
so if we're gonna keep scoring 109 we
got to keep them to 108 and that's the
biggest thing they scored 123 points
scored
you know she had 52% so it was more
about their play their execution
offensively their shot making our
offense could have been better obviously
we didn't shoot it great but you know
give them credit and they outplayed us
Joanna from Brazil to keel over zero was
about to ask you about the 109 points
that you scored pretty much in all the
games in every game still you see this
as a coincident so it shows what does it
show to you that is more like you want
with this score and you lost with the
same score so it's more about like
stopping the Raptors yes
defense defense wins in the playoffs
especially in the finals so we got to
play better defense Dan on the right
side coaching there right over here yeah
you mentioned you know their execution
on offense being a real problem for you
especially early Kyle Lowry seems to be
a real bellwether for that you know
you'd help to sort of held him down in
the first couple sort of held him down
in the first couple games breaks loose
tonight what did you see from him that
sort of as he what kind of problems did
he give you tonight
I think Kyle said accattone played a
great game for them and set of really
good tone early made some shots control
the game and so he was he was a huge
factor for them art last question of the
second row Steve art spanger the Maven
everyone assumed she missed clays points
but clays points but wasn't his defense
is important and perhaps that's why they
shot so well well yeah I mean plays one
of our best defenders so but again that
doesn't matter
you know guys guys hurt doesn't play
then you you you play the next guy and
as I said I'm very very proud as I said
I'm very very proud of the way our guys
competed and played we didn't play well
enough and we ran into a team that
played an excellent game so black will
move on from here Thanks Thank You coach